Frozen your Source make between 750 and
800 000 a year the average Menchie Zone
earth makes ninety three thousand
dollars a year not as sexy as I thought
it was when I was trying to get into it
I thought eight hundred thousand a year
that means I make 800 000 a year I'm
Gonna Be Rich doesn't really work that
way and it's also a business that has
variable costs that are high so the more
yoga people buy the more actual cost of
goods that you have in order to fill on
it the average store that we're talking
about is 21.91 a day in Revenue what
does that mean in owner pay means 328
dollars a day in owner pay and so when
you walk in you're like man these guys
must be printing money well you've got
strawberries that are going bad machines
that are breaking in the back car cost
of yogurt a retail lease that's nice
prominently located with good signage
Good Foot traffic good traffic in front
of it ample parking if you wanted to buy
into a franchise most franchises have
six percent ish that goes straight to
them like there's lots of other things
that go into this business